two point two of the points that define
a certain quadrilateral are zero comma
nine and three comma four the
quadrilateral is left unchanged by a
reflection over the line y is equal to
three minus x draw and classify the
quadrilateral now I encourage you to
pause this video and try to draw and
classify it on your own before I'm about
to explain it so let's at least plot the
information they give us so the point
zero zero comma nine that's one of the
vertices of the quadrilateral so zero
comma nine that's that point right over
there and another vert vert is another
one of the vertices is three comma four
three comma four that's that right over
there and then they tell us that the
quadrille is left is left unchanged by
reflection over the line y is equal to
three minus x so when X is zero Y is
three that's our y-intercept and it has
a slope of negative one you could view
this as three minus one X so it has a
slope of negative one so the line looks
like this so every time we increase our
X we buy one we decrease our y by one so
the line looks something like this y is
equal to three minus x try to draw it
relatively very pretty carefully pretty
carefully so that's what it looks like Y
is equal to three minus x so that's my
best attempt at drawing it y is equal to
three minus X so the quadrilateral is
left unchanged by a reflection over this
so that means if I were to reflect each
of these vertices I would essentially
end up with one of the other vertices on
it and if those get reflected you're
going to end up with one of these so the
thing is not going to be different so
let's think about where these other two
vertices of this quadrilateral need to
be so this point let's just reflect it
over this line over Y is equal to three
minus X so if we were to try to drop a
perpendicular to this line notice we
have gone diagonally across one two
three of these squares we need to go
diagonally across three of them on the
left hand side so one two three gets us
right over there that's the reflection
this point this is the reflection of
this point across that line now let's do
the same thing for this blue point to go
to drop a perpendicular to this to this
line we have to go diagonally across two
of these squares so let's go diagonally
across two more of these squares just
like that to get to that point right
over there and now we've defined our
quadrilateral our quadrilateral looks
like this
our quadrilateral looks like this both
of these lines are perpendicular to that
original line so they're going to have
the same slope so that line is parallel
to that line over there and then we have
this line we have this line and then we
have this line so what type of
quadrilateral is this well I have one
pair of parallel one pair of parallel
sides so this is a this is a trapezoid